[Music]
travel is really heating up this summer
after over a year of pandemic related
restrictions
now a new program is allowing those who
haven't gotten the coronavirus vaccine a
way to travel abroad
the partnership between care now urgent
care and american airlines allows
travelers to get tested quickly
before their trip madison kimbrough
joins us live near tropicana and jones
tonight with more
madison yeah sasha the great thing about
this location is that it's open
24 hours and it's one of 16 locations
that las vegas go to to get tested fast
ahead of their travel a lot of our las
vegas
community are traveling right now and
the coven 19 requirements are so
confusing and so this partnership with
american airlines
is really wonderful because we take all
of that guess work out of it for our
community
american airlines and care now urgent
care have partnered up to provide
covet 19 rapid testing to american
airline travelers in vegas
with las vegas being a key destination
for travel in and out of the city
this allows unvaccinated american
airline guests to quickly get tested
and get their results all in one step dr
lamont tyler with
hca care now explains what you need in
order to get started
they have to have proof come in with
their ticket and reservation
we actually allow for our patients to do
what we call as a web check-in
which is online check-ins then we can
bring them back get the testing done for
them
and then facilitate them leaving with
the results and tests in here
these pre-flight covet 19 rapid tests
are for american airline guests
traveling to 13 international
destinations
including places throughout central
america the caribbean and on domestic
destinations like hawaii
as for other airlines jumping on board
and doing the same
tyler says the possibility is definitely
there we have been very successful
with our american airlines platform it
would not surprise me
if other airlines look at what we've
been able to put forth in terms of a
platform
facilitating safe travel and while this
is a quick fix for travelers that need
covet 19 results right away
it is an out-of-pocket expense that will
cost you 139 dollars
again these rapid tests are only
available to american airline travelers
and if you're interested in booking your
own appointment we have all that
information up on our website at eight
newsnow dot com
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now